bonsoir nous sommes le 10 octobre
nouvelle édition du 7 8 l'actu sur tv
fil 78 nous faisons le tour de
l'actualité locale comme chaque soir en
direct à 18 heures voici un aperçu des
principaux sujets qui seront développées
ce soir le premier ministre a effectué
ce matin une visite sur le plateau de
saclay un coup de pouce au développement
du projet surnommé la silicon valley à
la française et qui ont pas ce qui est
le directeur général délégué le de
l'établissement public paris saclay et
leur dit et que cette édition 320 mètres
de long 60 mètres de denim et les choses
se précisent pour la future piste de ski
qui sera installé son colline weiler
pour effet le député de la 7e
circonscription des yvelines arnaud
richard responsable de l'idée y dans le
département il aura tout à l'heure le
point sur la campagne municipale et la
question des alliances également avec
l'ump à l'image du jour politique encore
ce sont les militants socialistes qui
sont appelés aux urnes depuis 17 heures
et jusqu'à 22 heures ils vont désigner
dans leur section elle est tête de liste
aux municipales de mars prochain comme
ici à saint cyr l'école le second tour
si besoin se déroulera le 17 octobre
certaines communes des yvelines ont déjà
tranché afin d'accélérer leur campagne
pour tenter de renverser quelques
municipalités à montigny par exemple
avec la désignation nous en avions parlé
de vivien et gasc d'autres villes où la
situation est plus délicate c'est à
maurepas puisque les adhérents doivent
départager le conseiller général ismaïl
à vannes d'hervé miclo l'un des adjoints
au maire actuel nous ferons le point sur
ce dossier dans notre édition de demain
est l'invité de ce journal je vous le
disais c'est guillaume parce qu'il est
bon soir que soit vous êtes le directeur
général délégué de l'établissement
public paris-saclay ce matin vous avez
reçu la visite du chef du gouvernement
et de plusieurs ministres dont la
ministre à l'enseignement supérieur et
la recherche au programme inauguration
d'un nouveau centre de recherche et
développement pour edf visite également
de ce campus paris saclay résumé de ce
déplacement en introduction de cette
séquence avant d'en parler plus en
détail reportage olivier maniscalco
patrick jacques de dixmude
mesdames messieurs il est toujours un
moment dans l'élaboration d'un grand
projet où tout bascule
tout bascule du rêve à la réalité et je
crois qu'avec paris saclay nous sommes à
ce moment-là vous devant andrew devait
nous devons en est parfaitement
conscient
le chantier de la silicon valley à la
française c'est parti initié dès 2007 le
projet paris saclay a enfin bouclé son
financement et peut donc démarrer le
premier ministre jean-marc ayrault était
ce matin sur le campus à gif-sur-yvette
pour inaugurer le centre de recherche et
développement d'edf il en a profité pour
annoncer que 85 millions d'euros
seraient débloqués pour la création d'un
centre de recherche sur les énergies
décarbonées projet scientifique unique
en france paris saclay va proposer une
idée simple faire se croiser sur un même
site étudiant chercheur enseignant et le
monde de l'entreprise le but être à la
pointe de l'innovation et faciliter la
création de start-up axé sur les
technologies de demain en fait en france
on a pas mal de peur n'a pas mal de
start up le problème c'est qu'un respect
de plafonds de verre et nous ce qu'on
pense c'est que par la proximité
du centre de recherches de paris de
paris saclay eh bien on va être un
facteur qui va aider ces pme à croître
c'est quand la recette qui a fait que la
silicon valley et la silicon valley nous
avec notre génie français bat on veut
faire la même chose mais avec nos moyens
et avec notre inventivité
selon les prévisions d'ici à 2030 600
mille mètres carrés de locaux
d'enseignement de bureaux et de
logements verront le jour côté
transports une liaison directe est prévu
entre l'aéroport d'orly et versailles un
cinquième de la recherche française
devraient se regrouper à terme sur sept
mille 700 hectares de terrain le coût
total du projet est estimé à près de 2,5
milliards d'euros
guillaume pas ce qui est en charge du
développement de ce secteur de cet
ensemble avec l'établissement public
paris saclay quelle est votre réaction à
cette visite de ce matin du gouvernement
cette pose de première pierre c'est un
peu une vitrine aussi pour paris saclay
très positive évidemment notre réaction
c'était un jour très important pour
paris saclay et le le le thème de la
visite du premier c'est le message qu'il
est qu'il est venu passer ses venues
pour rappeler les fondamentaux de ce
projet un grand projet scientifique
grands projets technologiques qui
s'inscrit dans un dans un contexte dans
le contexte d'un grand projet urbain un
grand projet d'aménagement et je crois
que l'extrait du discours que vous avez
choisi était le bon puisque le message
le plus fort de la journée
c'est un projet qui dure depuis un
certain temps c'est une réelle ou à la
formule c'est que ça n'est plus un rêve
c'est une réalité et le fait qu'il soit
venu poser la première pierre de ce
grand chantier d'edf et je me sens dit
un mot df ce sera au total 70 mille
mètres carrés avec un centre de
recherche et le centre de formation
des cadres et des salariés d'edf au même
endroit juste à côté de ce grand campus
intégré même à ce grand campus de
l'université paris saclay
excellente illustration de la
coopération dont on espère des fruits
nombreux entre la recherche publique et
la r&d privé paris saclay doit réussir
ce lien entre recherche et l'entreprise
s'est également extrait du discours de
jean marc ayrault vous êtes d'accord
forcément avec ça vous êtes en bonne
voie pour le réussir aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui j'espère j'espère qu'on
avance bien quand vous dites vous il
faut il faut être très inclusif il faut
dire nous l'établissement public dans
notre mission d'aménagement notre
mission de développement économique mais
il faut aussi dire j'ai vu dominique
vernay dans le petit reportage la
fondation de coopération scientifique
qui qui regroupe tous ses établissements
connus et prestigieux qui sont sur le
plateau qui vont bientôt y venir citons
les plus connus citons l'école
polytechnique l'université paris sud le
cea l'université versailles saint
quentin hec et puis citons ceux qui vont
venir centrale le msk chiens etc etc
l'institut télécom donc ça peut aussi
sont en bonne voie puisque l'université
paris saclay va devenir une réalité dès
l'année prochaine et ça aussi ça a été
salué par le premier ministre ce n'est
pas simple c'est même extrêmement
compliqué on va passer de 400 master au
total à une réorganisation pour en avoir
40 imaginez le travail de fourmi que
doivent mener les acteurs arrivent à
s'entendre justement et c'est
extrêmement compliqué mais les projets
les progrès sont là on peut déjà à le
dire il y aura l'année à partir de la
création de cette université une unique
école doctorale donc le doctorat sera
labellisé université paris saclay et ça
va donner une visibilité formidable à ce
projet en france et bien au delà puisque
immédiatement l'unité paris saclay sera
parmi les meilleurs du monde juste une
parenthèse paris saclay c'est un projet
qui a été lancé par nicolas sarkozy par
le précédent gouvernement sous une autre
couleur politique aujourd'hui vous avez
toutes les assurances que le nouveau
gouvernement que le parti socialiste va
soutenir quelles que soient les
décisions qui ont été prises auparavant
l'avancée du chantier aujourd'hui tout
le monde quelle que soit la couleur
politique marcheurs vers le même sens je
crois qu'on peut le dire et je joue
c'est encore une composante à la fin de
mon ma réponse
c'est un chantier effectivement qui a
été lancée à l'époque du lancement du
show de l'hôte d'un autre grand chantier
dont il n'est qu'une partie le grand
paris c'était un chantier du grand paris
et je crois qu'avec les messages que
passe le premier ministre qu'il avait
déjà passé l'année dernière dans une
intervention il à peu près un an c'est
devenu un chantier du nouveau grand
paris donc les fondamentaux demeurent
les mêmes
ensuite chacun se réapproprie évidemment
le gouverneur requis lot ça forcément un
peu différent mais les fondamentaux
demeurent les mêmes et donc ce projet
aujourd'hui fait consensus et je vais
plus loin
nous sommes ici en train de travailler
l'établissement public il a été créé par
la rue du grand paris ça fait trois ans
que nous sommes de travail sur ce sur ce
sujet est un immense progrès depuis
trois ans et qui est maintenant un
consensus beaucoup plus fort avec les
élus locaux les élus des deux
départements des conseils de conseils
généraux et puis yvelines essonne qu'il
vit les variations est à cheval sur les
paris saclay est à cheval sur les deux
départements on pourra développer ce
point et puis les maires sur les
communes dès qu'elles se passent tous
ces développements et on sait que ce
n'est pas forcément simple à gérer pour
un maire lors de tels projets qui
arrivent sur sa commune et la visite de
ce matin c'était aussi pour rassurer un
petit peu tout le monde rassuré les
acteurs de terrain je pense tu penses
vous avez ce tueur sans doute aussi
entendu le premier ministre assurer sur
le fait que le métro du grand paris
viendra bien avec sa ligne 18 connectés
paris saclay à l'ensemble de la région
ile de france et ça c'est un point
essentiel sans ça il ne peut pas y avoir
un tel projet donc je pense j'espère en
tout cas que les messages passent et que
et que les gens sont rassurés puisque
vous parlez des transports justement ce
matin ce sont nos confrères du parisien
qui annonce que le prix du ticket de
métro près augmenté de 3% par an sur dix
ans pour financer ce super métro en
rocade autour de paris sans compter
aussi une hausse de la tva de 7 à 10% au
1er janvier ce qui inquiète tant
forcément même le président est de
région ile-de-france le président jean
paul huchon des répercussions aussi dans
l'opinion publique la hausse il va y
avoir un travail aussi à faire passer
c'est que ce grand paris ce paris saclay
cette importance est important pour
développer l'économie développer l'image
de la france était bien falloir le
financer aussi et tout le monde va
devoir contribuer
le grand métro effectivement alors il ya
la ligne 18 qui passe de donc d'orly à
versailles en passant par le campus et
puis par 51 en yvelines qui est celle
qui nous concerne nous au quotidien mais
qui s'inscrit dans un système beaucoup
plus grands qui était un plan
d'investissement compte que le
gouvernement a baptisé nouveau grand
paris exceptionnels comme on en connaît
bien tous les cinquante ans en ile de
france pour remettre le cil le système à
niveaux du niveau de population qui sont
là et répondre à l'exigence de
l'ensemble des citoyens aucun doute ça
coûte très cher mais alors moi je je
aucun doute non plus et rentable c'est
rentable
à moyen et à court terme et évidemment à
long terme sur l'impact que ça en cas
passés en qualité de vie pour les gens
en valeur de l'habitat tout autour et en
attractivité économique de la région qui
aujourd'hui quand on a lancé le métro le
métro parisien en 1903 je suis sûr que
nos prédécesseurs avaient des débats
identique ça va coûter très cher tout ça
qui aujourd'hui peut dire que ça a été
un mauvais investissement eh ben je suis
persuadé que dans 50 ans on dira la même
chose sur le métro et pour l'instant
rien n'est tranché en cette hausse de 3%
par an c'est qu'une d une des pistes ses
prêts une annonce qu'on fait tout de
même ce soir puisqu'on parle argent en
revanche classée c'est plus concret une
nouvelle mobilisation de 85 millions
d'euros pour faire du campus paris
saclay un leader mondial de la recherche
scientifique et universitaire c'est ce
qui a été annoncé ce matin par le chef
du gouvernement donc en déplacement sur
ce plateau de saclay ses 66 millions
pour un institut de transfert
technologie 19 millions pour un centre
de recherche sur les énergies
décarbonées plus concrètement cet argent
va servir à quoi comment il va être
affecté cette nouvelle enveloppe alors
ces deux enveloppes d'abord sont
attribués à paris saclay au terme de
d'appel d'offres et de mise en
concurrence c'est le principe du grand
emprunt le grand emprunt lancé le lance
des appels d'offres les candidats
partout en france y réponde et les
meilleurs sont sélectionnés et
obtiennent des financements les deux
lignes que vous citez la première est
donc annoncée aujourd'hui confirmée
aujourd'hui par le par le premier
ministre dont paris saclay lauréats la
première s'appelle une société
d'accélération des transferts de
technologie en quoi ça consiste ça
consiste à à l'intérieur de l'université
paris saclay mettre ensemble la gestion
des transferts de technologies des
brevets etc pour faire effet masse ce
qui est ce qui a un impact très fort
pour ce genre de choses donc ça s'éteint
c'est un nouvel institut qui sera le
service de transfert de technologie
universités c'est extrêmement important
le deuxième je peux peut-être en dire un
peu plus c'est le projet qu'on appelle
ps2 paris-saclay efficacité énergétique
et ça illustre très bien l'ambition de
ce projet à trois niveaux d'abord c'est
c'est un projet
intégré avec les avec les acteurs de la
science on y trouve plusieurs instituts
de recherche ans d'école l'université
tout membre de paris saclay qui qui qui
collabore ensuite on y trouve également
les industriels edf dont on vient de
parler air liquide dans les îles loges
en josas qui est un acteur majeur de ce
projet donc coopération public privé
pour faire de la du transfert de
technologie le thème de sa part il sait
que l'efficacité énergétique c'est
l'efficacité est là et là comment dire
la flexibilité énergétique des
installations industrielles on voit bien
l'enjeu derrière pour l'ensemble de
l'industrie nationale être à meilleur
coût et puis saisir ces nouveaux marchés
qui intéresse tous les industriels du
monde et puis ensuite troisième exemple
3e 3e belle illustration de ce beau
projet ps2 c'est que ça s'inscrit dans
un territoire sur lequel les questions
énergétiques sont près de nantes quand
on construit autant de mètres carrés que
ce qu'on va construire autour de ce
campus et aux alentours réfléchir très
en amont avec des acteurs scientifiques
de cette qualité à comment on fait pour
que la ville soit économe en énergie
voire à énergie positive voilà des
partenaires qu on est très content
d'avoir avec nous pour nous accompagner
et nous aider à faire des choses
intelligentes vous avez mentionné le
terme campus et j'aimerais juste qu'on
s'arrête là-dessus pour conclure cet
entretien ce n'est pas qu'un campus
paris saclay c'est beaucoup plus large
que ça on va en profiter pour repréciser
vraiment votre rôle pour l'établissement
public qui couvrent 49 communes quatre
communautés d'agglomération sur deux
départements yvelines et essonne alors
ce n'est pas qu'une université ce pack
un campus paris saclay quelque chose
soit bien que bien sûr tout on parle
beaucoup du campus et pour une raison
simple c'est que si en plus il n'y
aurait pas ce projet mais ce campus
n'est surtout pas une île isolée du
monde et en premier lieu il doit
extrêmement bien connectée c'est
d'ailleurs l'un des enjeux du métro du
grand paris aux zones d'activités
économiques alentours on peut citer
vélizy on peut citer but qu on peut
citer l'ensemble économique de 51 ans et
vit avec des grands comptes que vous
connaissez thales eads renault en est
implanté le site et courtaboeuf côté
essonniens massy etc
l'enjeu c'est que ces entreprises là ils
trouvent leur compte et que le projet
aille bien au delà nous établissements
publics notre première mission c'est
évidemment l'aménagement ont fait
l'aménagement du campus mais on
travaille aussi avec les élus et la
communauté économique
pour je dirais faire monter en gamme
tout et autres soupes ces zones
économiques l entoure cet archipel de
grandes zones économiques les rendre
plus attractives plus dynamique
certaines ont la capacité de croissance
d'autres ne peuvent se renouveler tout
en tout cas peuvent bénéficier de ce qui
se passe au coeur de ce campus et d'un
ce grand projet paraît simple mais on
verra dans les prochaines années comment
évolue ce dossier paris-saclay merci
avant d'être revenu sur ce podium
pasquier puis je rappelle que jean marc
ayrault était ce matin à saclay un pont
pour montrer le soutien du gouvernement
au développement paris-saclay reportage
résumé de ce déplacement du premier
ministre du gouvernement voir sur notre
site internet dès à présent avant
d'imaginer un ensemble grand paris
saclay la réalité pour les communes
s'est pour l'instant leur groupe
obligatoire en intercommunalité pour
celles qui n'avaient pas encore franchi
le pas il en reste quelques unes ce
regroupement sera opérationnelle au 1er
janvier du côté des yvelines la
préfecture vient de trancher maurepas et
coignières seront rattachés à la
communauté de communes des étangs avec
notamment le perret et les essarts
l'hypothèse d'un rapprochement avec
saint quentin en yvelines avait un temps
été évoquée ce n'était qu'une rumeur
vieille de 20 ans et pourtant la colline
d'elancourt pourrait être transformée en
piste de ski un projet étonnant qui
reste pour l'instant encore secret
malgré des avancées significatives que
les principaux intéressés ne veulent pas
toujours commentée vous allez le voir
les derniers éléments de ce dossier avec
anthony rech
320 mètres de long 60 m de dénivelé
voilà à quoi pourrait ressembler la
future piste de ski d'elancourt mais
avant de slalomer il va falloir
patienter encore quelques années pour
l'instant seuls des échanges sont en
cours entre le promoteur du projet
sodéarif et la ville afin de vérifier la
compatibilité technique et
environnemental d'un ski dôme sur le
point culminant d'ile-de-france après
avoir modifié son plan local d'urbanisme
en fin d'année dernière la ville prévoit
de lancer une enquête publique dans les
prochains mois ça fait 30 ans que cette
colline
d'elancourt
et c'est comme ça de façon sauvage il ya
eu plusieurs projets qui ont été
bloquées les haines donc c'est vrai
qu'il faudra un jour ici de valoriser
pour la clé de saint pierre se se sont
quand même ce magnifique site voila vous
accueilli la plus élevée d'ile-de-france
est vrai qu'on est vrai qu'il ya demain
un bon restaurant qu'ils soient là haut
des pistes de glisse des pistes de
promenade pour les familles autres
partenaires du dossier la communauté
d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines ne souhaite
pas pour l'instant s'exprimer
le ski dôme abritera des pistes allant
de 100 mètres pour les leçons à 320
mètres pour les plus expérimentés vous
pourrez apprendre le ski pour 19 euros
95 par heure et profiter de la piste
pour 40 euros la journée à l'extérieur
le public pourra profiter d'un parc de
plein air avec luge d'été et d'un
magasin spécialisé en équipements de
sports d'hiver au total la piste élan
courtoise devrait générer près de 200
emplois enfin sur le plan financier le
projet serait uniquement à la charge du
spécialiste hollandais de ce qu'ils
nomment snowboard à hauteur de 50
millions d'euros le permis de construire
devrait être délivré pour la fin d'année
2014 et les saint quentinois pour et
skier à noël 2016
ça fait sourire mais ce qu est l encours
ce sera sans doute une réalité il y
croyez vous et surtout cela vous fait-il
rêver c'est forcément la question que
nous sommes allez vous poser aujourd'hui
micro-trottoir la question du jour au
micro trottoir de la rédaction
peut-être plaire aux jo je pourrais être
sympa pour ceux comme les skis une bonne
idée c'est génial
c'est génial c'est bien pour les
habitants c'est bien pour les coques
pour les commerçants ça va donner un peu
de coups de fouet au commerce blog de la
crise en pierre moi je fais du surf ont
rêvé c'est toujours sympa mais il
faudrait un peu plus de choses
aujourd'hui vélo si tous à aménager ans
je pense qu'il fallait pas mal de choses
à faire là dessus sur ce site là donc
bon mais c'est pas mal c'est vrai que
c'est une bonne idée si ça se fait ça
peut être sympa pour tous les jeunes qui
n'ont pas la possible par thirau ce qui
est un plus mais mr s'amuser midi
nous allons reparler politique à présent
dans ce set 8 l'actuel udi
départementale qui vient de présenter
ses premières à tête de liste pour les
municipales de mars prochain une
quinzaine d'investiture a été donné sur
notre secteur dans le département
véronique côté millard mary des idées
clayes-sous-bois reçu logiquement
l'investiture investit également au
ministre denis quand un bout le fils de
nicolas avoue l'ancien maire
emblématique de montigny le bretonneux
pour mort pas le président de l'udps et
départementale a tranché on se souvient
à des tensions entre l'ancien premier
adjoint udi qui souhaite le soutien de
l'ump tout comme le responsable ump de
la ville on devait le pire le guérinel
grégory gare et astier mais pour arnaud
un richard responsable de l'ue des ide
dans le département la situation est
claire il ne mâche pas ses mots
d'ailleurs c'était au micro de catherine
je l'attends l'alliance l'ump midi entre
nicole malaquin et pierre le guérinel et
le ticket gagnant est ce que la plupart
des observateurs à part un ou deux pour
des raisons qui m'échappent je veux même
pas comprendre tout le monde en est
convaincu et la situation elle est assez
clair après la question qu'on peut se
poser c'est est ce que tout le monde a
envie de gagner moore pas question
difficile à laquelle ceux qui
connaissent le terrain pourront répondre
assez facilement - je veux qu'on gagne
ment pas et je veux qu'on gagne ment pas
avec pierre le guérinel et nicole manach
est ce que c'est un message que vous
adressez à grégory qu'un restiez
poursuit pour tout le monde c'est pour
tout le monde c'est pour tous celles et
ceux qui connaissent le situation locale
et puis je pense surtout aux mort pas y
aller aux morts passe bien pour qui tous
ces petits arrangements entre amis pas
bien clair avec des gens qui
s'autoproclament les gens qui jure peu d
identité politique moi je trouve pas ça
bien
arnaud richard qui en profite donc pour
mettre les points sur les i à l'encontre
d'erwan le gall qui se présente comme le
responsable sur maurepas du parti
radical eu d une des composantes de
l'udf parti radical écoutez c'est un
militant qui s'est beaucoup autoproclamé
mais qui n'a pas plus d'importance que
ça voilà bah c'est pas parce qu'on dit
beaucoup sur les réseaux sociaux et
qu'on s'auto proclame qu'on a de
l'importance la décision de l'ue des
prises après s'il ne contente pas tout
le monde chacun libre de démissionner du
parti quand l'addition ne convient pas
et de son côté gregori galtier qui a
annoncé aujourd'hui même qu'à roanne le
gall qu'il désigne donc toujours comme
représentant du parti radical udi de
maurepas devenait officiellement le
président de son comité de soutien pour
les élections municipales de mars sur
cette ville de maurepas autres cas
pointilleux celui de
voisins-le-bretonneux alexandra rosetti
maire-adjointe udi a choisi à deux
monter une liste contre le maire sortant
l'ump alexis piette elle a démissionné
de son poste d'adjointe d'ailleurs
vernon richard est prudent c'est une
décision récente elle nous en a informés
nous a écrit pour nous le dire nous
n'avons pas statué encore sur le sujet
puisque c'était très récent je crois que
ça date du 1er octobre assurément aux
étiquettes au courant ah oui bien sûr et
aux courbes en famille un moment il ya
tout un processus de décision qu'il y
avait suffisamment décision à prendre
comme ça dimanche dernier mais
effectivement nous auront à statuer sur
ce sujet avec l'ump et puis avec les
forces en présence
90% des têtes de listes de l'éluder
devait être connue d'ici la fin du mois
d'octobre avec l'ump départementale
menée par valérie pécresse pour
l'instant les discussions sont ouvertes
alors avec l'ump ça se passe comment
vous dire ça se passe pas trop mal pour
l'instant voilà je me ferai tout pour
que ça dure il ya un certain nombre de
communes pour lesquelles il n'y a pas de
sujet les sortants on voit bien qu il ya
des pannes des maires passent la main ça
se passe plutôt intelligemment on a des
mêmes des candidats communs je pense là
conflent évidemment à chanteloup
évidemment aux mureaux et puis à des
situations maurepas en études on n'est
pas toujours d'accord donc on essaye de
s'accorder de façon la plus objective
possible dans une matière qui n'est pas
objective d'avoir le meilleur candidat
commun l'idée quand même d'avoir une
union donc on doit pouvoir s'accorder et
puis si on s'accorde pas on ira chacun
au premier tour avec des accords
d'alliance au second mais je crois que
sur tout ce qui est important dans une
formation politique c'est que celles et
ceux qui n'auront pas été choisie joue
le jeu c'est trop facile d'être membre
d'un parti politique et quand on est pas
investie de dire j'y vais quand même sur
le parti parce que dans ces cas là on
joue pas avec les règles qui sont celles
d'une formation politique
on quitte la politique tout au long de
cette semaine nous suivons la 10e
mobilisation autour du handicap à
montigny le bretonneux aujourd'hui jeudi
philippe ribière champion d' escalade
athlètes handisport est venu rencontrer
elle les plus jeunes au gymnase pierre
de coubertin leçon de courage de patio
également anthony rech elodie moi
je m'appelle philippe
je suis né en martinique à 1977
je suis atteint du syndrome de pêche tv
un polyhandicap avec plusieurs
malformations
j'ai été abandonné par mon papa et ma
maman
des raisons inconnues
à l'âge de 4 ans j'ai été adopté par une
famille française
c'est
il y à 16 ans j'ai découvert l'escaladé
qui a changé ma vie
m
en fait j'essaie de transmettre un petit
peu aux enfants que c'est
la différence sous forme de jeu parce
que je calme du calme qu'un avenant des
rigolos en quelque part et j'essaie de
leur expliquer à ma façon ce qui nous
est pas un problème en fait le handicapé
par romain problème c'est pas super dur
de grimper avec mon handicap c'est juste
moi je connais que ça tu peux pas
comparer avec toi quoi mais
effectivement dans le milieu beaucoup
s'accordent à dire que je fait vachement
plus dur que ce que font les autres
depuis c'est un fait je vais pas changer
et puis voilà je suis satisfait de ça
est ce que je dis souvent aux enfants
c'est que l'otan avant mon handicap a
été longtemps un source de problèmes
autant maintenant c'est mon outil de
travail
concepteur de tous à dire qu'elle est
une personne handicapée ouais
effectivement c'est pas super cool bon
ça s'arrête là et je vois pas plus de
problèmes que ça sauf que effectivement
on y voit accessibilité en mode pour les
trains taxi restaurant tout ça là on est
à la masse qu on est vraiment en retard
toujours cette leçon de courage de
philippe rivière du temps gagné à
présent pour les usagers avec une
convention signée à la cour
administrative d'appel pour la
dématérialisation des documents de
justice ils entre jonathan willeman qui
nous donne plus de précisions à présent
la juridiction se met à l'ère numérique
dès le mois de décembre dans toute la
métropole une nouvelle application va
permettre un échange par voie
électronique des requêtes des mémoires
ou encore de tous les avis entre la
juridiction et des requérants de même
que vous pouvez aujourd'hui
remplir une déclaration d'impôts en
ligne de même que vous achetez un billet
de train ou un billet d'avion en ligne
vous pourrez à l'avenir dès lors que
vous êtes une administration ou que vous
êtes représenter par un avocat faire de
la même façon saisir le juge
administratif en première instance ou en
appel par la voie dématérialisée par la
voix de l'internet en réalité
l'application app l'été les recours
c'est donc plus de rapidité et moins de
papier la convention signée à versailles
avec les bâtonniers va leur permettre de
gérer ensemble la future application est
d'inciter à son utilisation car elle ne
sera pas obligatoire juste recommandé
justice les avocats en colère contre la
chancellerie elle avait annoncé une
réforme de l'aide juridictionnelle qui
aboutissait à une baisse de l'indemnité
versée aux avocats dans ce type de
dossier des avocats qui discute depuis
pourtant dix ans pour une revalorisation
un mouvement de grève avait même
traversé le pays la semaine dernière
le bâtonnier de l'ordre des avocats de
versailles nous donne plus
d'explications la chancellerie nous a
entendus puisque la ministre vendredi
matin a annoncé qu'elle renonçait à
cette réforme qui aboutissait cette
diminution les discussions sont
réouvertes nous avons maintenant à
discuter à négocier avec la chancellerie
non seulement une l'abandon de cette
réforme est une mauvaise idée
négociations et une augmentation de
l'indemnité qui n'a pas été indexé
depuis 2007 on allait presque terminée
je vous propose de revoir l'image du
jour ce sont les militants socialistes
appelés aux urnes depuis 17 heures et
jusqu'à 22 heures ils vont désigner dans
leur section les têtes de liste aux
municipales de mars prochain la commissi
à saint-cyr-l'ecole second tour si
nécessaire 17 octobre certaines communes
des yvelines avait déjà tranché à leur
tête de liste pour accélérer leur
campagne comme à montigny avec la
désignation de vivien et gasc et dans
d'autres communes situation plus
délicate à maurepas notamment où les
adhérents à jour de cotisations doivent
trancher entre landes et anciens est
l'un des maires adjoints pardon hervé
miclo socialiste donc et le conseiller
général ismaila vannes socialiste
également ils veulent l'investiture de
leur parti pour ces municipales un
dossier sur lequel nous reviendrons
demain dans le journal de la rédaction
dès 18 heures j'en à la retrouver devant
votre télé également sur votre
ordinateur ou sur votre smartphone
rediffusion 19h 22h30 minuit excellente
soirée et adore
m